qui protège les actionnaires de total
on les aurait pas écouté
heureusement ce que vous êtes partis
vite je me suis dit attention peut-être
trop vite tous les grands
révolutionnaires en fait sont des ratés
quelque chose parfois l'écriture parfois
politique parfois les avocats et ils
sont devenus militants et c'était tous
des ratés et c'est la phrase de Bernanos
les raté de vous rattrapont pas c'est
comme un capteur d'activité dans votre
crâne avec des petits fils la puce est
implantée dans le cerveau grâce à ce
robot chirurgien l’activité cérébrale y
est mesurée de manière ultra précise
quelle six lettres s'il vous plaît
Lucienne
et d'un gourou
avant la Révolution ils avaient tenté
certains allaient tenter d'écrire échec
certains avaient tenté d'être avocat
échec certains et c'est vrai que il y a
des gens dont tu te dis que j'entends
parfois dans l'espace médiatique ils ne
peuvent être humilitants la seule chose
qui peut faire mais pas parce que s'il
tente autre chose ils auront du mal
jusqu'ici les tests sont pratiqués sur
des cochons ou encore sur ce singe
capable de jouer à ce jeu vidéo grâce à
sa pensée mais la société américaine
n'est pointée du doigt sur la question
de la souffrance animale
stop
ah bah oui le milliardaire ne veut pas
se faire doubler par ses concurrents
sous sa pression des salariés seraient
ainsi poussés à bâcler des tests et
sacrifierait parfois
inutilement certains de ces animaux
grâce à Photoshop on peut déjà retoucher
modifier une photo mais bientôt son
utilisation sera simplifiée grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle il suffira
d'écrire ce que l'on veut changer
exemples ajoutez une ligne jaune au sol
ou bien placer ce serre dans une ruelle
sombre et humide à peine écrit déjà
l'écran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme les anges n'a pas de sexe et c'est
sans doute pourquoi c'est lui qui passe
l'aspirateur
il arrive carotte parfois se fâche le
jour de notre visite par exemple il
voulait rejoindre son copain R2D2 à la
maison je fais tout et j'ai une épouse
qui sait tout faire au sein à la maison
je fais tout et j'ai appris à faire ce
qu'un homme ne faisait pas je suis un
grillon du foyer là je lance une
candidature je suis très bien dans ma
vie ma tribunal mais je peux prendre
aujourd'hui la gestion des maisons je
sais m'occuper des enfants découvrent je
connais tous les problèmes et c'est
formidable pour fêter ça notre expert
que le combat a démangé toute la journée
ne résiste pas à affronter un adversaire
à sa hauteur Lucile
et voilà
tu es trop forte et la sérénité de mon
couple elle vient de là voilà j'en sais
plus quel sur la lingerie sur la layette
sur l'entretien j'en sais plus que ma
femme c'est moi le chef à la maison
voilà
qui se bougent les fesses à la maison
ils sont pas si nombreux que ça pourquoi
moi je suis jaune
on commence
alors c'est quoi l'opération de
chirurgie esthétique et la plus réclamée
chez vous l'augmentation mammaire ah bah
on y revient toujours
et le divorce laissez-moi qui suivent en
général
l'augmentation ma mère
six mois après avoir six mois avant ou
dans les six mois qui suivent
des sifflets des remarques déplacées ou
même des agressions sexuelles 9 femmes
sur 10 affirment avoir été importuné
dans les transports en commun
je crois que je vais faire serrer au
métro je pense que ça va pas être la
dernière c'est une réalité des
chercheurs avaient fait une enquête
auprès des hommes et c'était aperçu que
si on cumulé le temps que les hommes
entre 18 et 50 ans passés à regarder les
femmes mais à les scruter quoi et
regarder attentivement c'était une année
de vie et en gros ça fait à peu près 3/4
d'heure par jour à mater les nanas
si vous prenez le métro n'oubliez pas
votre Subway shirt
traduisez chemise de métro pour
dissimuler une tenue légère un réflexe
déjà adopté par ses parisiennes malgré
elle
voilà
[Musique]
faut pas oublier Kinshasa aujourd'hui
c'est la première ville francophone au
monde où il y a le plus de personnes par
français c'est Kinshasa j'y suis allée
j'ai adoré l'électricité de cette ville
la vibration
il y a des mots il y a des mots qui font
pas dire
[Applaudissements]
on finit dans la neige il paraît que
c'est très bon pour la santé
c'est pas vrai en fait EDF parle de 2000
ans avec eux
m'avez en vrai je peux pas la fermer je
peux pas vous affirmer qu'il y avait des
électricité au sommet des pyramides etc
je peux pas le signer sur un papier
c'est moi je pense que le sujet de
l'Egypte devrait rester quelque chose de
fascinant de mystérieux
c'est la vérité c'est que vous regrettez
pas non je regrette quand je blesse les
gens si je blesse la polémique sur bonne
année c'était une connerie sûr j'ai dit
ça vous dites les pyramides vous dites
est-ce que j'ai blessé quelqu'un est-ce
que j'ai fait du mal est-ce que
quelqu'un
je suis désolé si pour les pyramides en
électricien
[Applaudissements]
ok ça bien
vous venez de voir
film sans scénariste
[Applaudissements]